[Music]
on this Sunday night the police
investigation into a Quebec care home
the cases of kovat piled up at the
long-term care facility this is why
we've characterized these homes as
tinderboxes with no warnings to the
families Trump's plan to get America
back to business
we're winning the war but our lives at
risk with worries about a second wave of
the virus Boris Johnson out of hospital
but the British Prime Minister hasn't
bounced back from kovat just yet and
doing Easter differently
the holy streams for the flock
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with developments
from that care home in Quebec where 31
people died in less than a month at
least five of them had covin 19 the
provincial coroner's office announced it
will investigate the fatalities that's
in addition to investigations by
quebec's health department and police as
authorities look for answers families
are demanding to know how their loved
ones could be left in such deplorable
conditions my clica ture reports Kyra
White had spent her Easter Sunday
outside the Heron residents looking for
answers she knows her 89 year old father
had kovat 19 and died here on Friday
that's all the information she's been
given I feel I feel worse because I
don't know if my dad was lying in theses
or not I don't know I don't know I don't
know anything I haven't seen few have
seen the inside of the residence where
31 seniors have died in less than a
month the major crimes unit of the
Montreal police force is now
investigating as is Quebec scorner we're
collecting also documents that we're
seizing notably
the stuff like work schedule list of
employees different types of evidence
police say the investigation could take
weeks or even months
Quebec premier France while ago has
described it as a possible case of gross
negligence with reports of residents
being left in beds of their own
excrement and despite those difficult
conditions social worker Mandy Novak
felt she had to come to volunteer her
help there's a smell in there and it's a
smell of the deceased
and of wounds that need to be taken care
of and we're not taking care of for a
long time the province has said at least
five of the 31 deaths inside the home
were linked to covet 19 the number of
Canadian long-term care homes that have
been ravaged by the virus continues to
rise hundreds of facilities across the
country have been hit by outbreaks with
elderly populations being more
susceptible to the virus this is why
we've characterized these homes as
tinderboxes dr. Samir Sinha helped the
federal government develop recently
released national guidelines for
long-term care facilities to protect
them from outbreaks with a so-called
iron ring procedures like preventing
people from working in multiple homes
and making sure both staff and residents
wear masks when we are having a case
appear in a home that were actually
promptly not only testing and isolating
those who look like they're symptomatic
but also recognizing that people could
have been infected who are asymptomatic
dr. Sinha acknowledges having those
guidelines in place a month ago could
have saved lives but he says having them
in place now will save many others
Michael accretor global news Ottawa
Quebec has been hit the hardest by Cova
19 the province now has more than 12,000
cases and 328 deaths overall Canada has
more than 24,000 cases over 19 has
claimed more than 700 lives in this
country for the first time in history
every US state is under a disaster
declaration there are more than 550,000
confirmed cases of Cova 19 in the u.s.
at least 21,000 people have died the
u.s. has suffered more Cova 19 deaths
than any other country in the world and
as Jennifer Johnson explains there's
concern more Americans could die if
President Trump reopens the economy too
soon a nation praying for hope this
Easter Sunday in some cases through
video
in a handful of states worshipers
ignored health experts and congregated
in churches this Easter will be much
different than others in his Easter
address US President Donald Trump
promised America will soon get back to
normal
despite kovat 19 infection and death
rates still on the rise it's a plague on
our country like nobody's ever seen but
we're winning the battle we're winning
the war
this week the president plans to meet
with his new task force on reopening the
economy with the targeted May 1st date
already his own health experts are
pushing back saying they still don't
have the right diagnostic tests to
protect people this team of experts all
of government approach they're focused
at looking at the earliest possible time
that we can get Americans back to wait
back to work safely and to give
Americans the confidence they need world
health experts also urging caution we
think it's going to be a virus that
Stokes the human race for quite a long
time to come until we can all have a
vaccine that will protect us the
nation's top infectious disease expert
now admits concerns about the economy
led the u.s. to wait too long mid-march
to order protective measures to stop the
spread of the virus obviously if we had
right from the very beginning shut
everything down it may have been a
little bit different but there was a lot
of pushback about shutting things down
back then as the virus keeps tens of
millions of Americans out of work food
banks are stretched to their limits
people waited in their cars for two
hours at this distribution site in
Hawaii I've never seen anything like it
but I don't think America has ever seen
anything like the Cova crisis that we're
having right now this this is
extraordinary meanwhile the Treasury
Department says tens of millions of
Americans will start receiving their
coronavirus stimulus payments next week
some hope on this Easter Sunday for
millions suffering from this pandemic
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
the global toll of this pernicious virus
is staggering there are more than 1.8
million confirmed cases of Cova 19
worldwide and more than a hundred and
thirteen thousand people have died from
kovat right now the UK is being hit
extremely hard recording more than
700 new deaths of Cova 19 in a 24-hour
time frame that takes the total number
of deaths there to over 10,000 but there
is some hope in Spain the rate of
infection has fallen still that country
recorded 619 deaths in the last day
British Prime Minister Boris Johnson is
out of hospital but he won't be rushing
back to work I have today left hospital
after a week in which the NHS has saved
my life
new question the 55 year old says his
life was on the line with Cova 19 and
the situation could have gone either way
if it wasn't for frontline health
workers Johnson was rushed to intensive
care on Monday and spent three nights in
ICU receiving oxygen Pope Francis
delivered Easter Sunday Mass in a
near-empty
st. Peter's Basilica as churches grapple
was celebrating one of the holiest days
of the year in a time when physical
distancing is a matter of life and death
the pontiff says the pandemic is testing
our whole human family and that this is
not a time for self-centeredness and
division only a handful of people were
inside the Basilica to assist with a
virtual service for worshippers to watch
from home it's in stark comparison to
last year when some 70 thousand people
filled Saint Peter's Square for the
service Italy is one of the worst hit
countries in the Cova 19 pandemic and
the religious community has not been
spared from the devastation according to
the New York Times at least a hundred
priests in Italy have died since the
outbreak hit that country when we come
out of this and we will come out of this
we will all take pride in the sacrifices
we've made to protect each other
and to protect the country we love Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau thanked
Canadians for doing their part to
prevent the spread of Cova 19 by keeping
up their physical distance this Easter
he also offered words of support for the
health care workers on the front lines
of the pandemic during a holiday weekend
for so many cultures including Passover
tamil new year
the Sikh holiday Vaisakhi Easter Sunday
services across Canada took on a much
different look this year with religious
leaders addressing congregations via
live streams it's a way of navigating
the difficult balance of keeping
tradition and practicing physical
distancing so necessary to protect our
communities from Cova 19 Global's Joe
Scarpelli shows us how churches are
adapting in these trying times you'd
never guess it was Easter Sunday judging
by the parking lot of this Winnipeg
church but there is a service happening
inside I don't think anybody's seen an
Easter like this before but I think the
church has learned to adapt and has
adapted very well for the first time
pastor Jerry Mitchell ski is live
streaming his Easter service to an empty
building families around the city tuning
in from home calves drinking his coffee
we're watching Church on the big screen
there similar celebrations taking place
around the country a church in Saskatoon
with its first ever virtual Easter choir
it took 70 hours to stitch together 40
videos of the people singing their parts
and this Toronto family is adapting
their festivities to suit the times a
virtual Easter this year for an 82 year
old grandmother who hasn't missed an
Easter Sunday Mass in her life I feel
sad because I know the church we had
kind of come through the back and just
stand outside the door and just gave our
wishes to each other and that was in
Calgary one church going drive-in movie
style for its service cars packing the
parking lot tuning into the radios and
watching the pastor on the big screen it
would be a record attendance for us like
for sure on any day
probably times one and a half or two so
yeah it's been busy for us a different
but unforgettable Easter Joel Scarpelli
Global News Winnipeg no outings no
gatherings no groceries without lineups
and for many
no prospect of work for months what has
become normal is anything but life under
Koba 19 is the focus of a new primetime
program by Global News it's called the
new reality it airs every Sunday at 7
p.m. and it's hosted by Donna freezin hi
Donna tell us what the new reality is
all about well Robin we know everyone's
living with uncertainty right now this
mysterious virus is lurking there's
anxiety about paying the bills and it's
really hard to make any plans for the
future and we have to stay physically
distant from people everyone wants to
know of course is this the new reality
well no one has the answer right now but
every week we're going to keep asking
the question and who are you talking to
this week well one of the people is dr.
Bonnie Henry she's BC's public health
officer she like all the other public
health officers in Canada is front and
center right now she's been giving
almost daily briefings for I think 12
weeks people absolutely love her I asked
her among other things how much it
weighs on her to strike the right
balance between giving people of facts
and not panicking them everything about
this has been so challenging and that
the sort of balance of trying to get
just enough restriction to do what we
need to do but not too much and it it
haunts me a little bit because you can't
ever get it just right we also talked to
an ER doctor about what happens to
people if they end up in the ICU and we
have a sampling of all that crazy funny
stuff people are putting on social media
people who have obviously way too much
time on their hands
Robin thanks for that Donna we'll all be
watching and you can watch the new
reality starting tonight and every
Sunday at 7 p.m. right here on global
coming up down the drain the pandemic
forces dairy farmers across Canada to
build their milk
dairy farmers are the latest to be
forced to change tactics because of the
pandemic producers are stuck with milk
normally sold to businesses that are now
closed and as Eric Sorenson reports
they're forced to dump their milk to
control the supply from this farm in
Wisconsin to the UK to Canada one of the
sad consequences of the pandemic has
been the dumping of millions of litres
of raw milk at first there was a milk
shortage as some people hoarded but the
real impact hit when restaurants and
other retailers shut down food service
sector curtailed significantly raw milk
that comes from cows is very perishable
producers say they can't turn off the
cows when demand is suddenly wiped out
for a product sensitive to balance
production so dairy farmers of Ontario
told 3400 producers this week to dispose
of their milk on a rotating basis other
provinces are doing the same the last
thing a farmer wants to do is dispose of
milk on the farm but for some dumping
milk however rare raises questions about
Canada's scheme of fixed milk prices for
many products from gasoline to
perishables like vegetables an
overabundance leads to a drop in prices
and then consumers buy more of that
product for a time that's not quite how
it works for milk in part because it is
governed by the supply management system
which keeps prices stable and dairy
farmers make a promise a guarantee
proper Silva and Charlevoix says under
supply management milk prices are set
and farmers based on quota will get paid
allowing an excess of milk at lower
costs into the marketplace is not part
of the formula right now producers don't
have to change they're paid for the
dairy farmers say Supply Management is
necessary to ensure a safe supply of
milk on store shelves that Canadians can
rely on the prices are a fair return for
farmers which allows us to be
sustainable but disposing of milk has on
this British farm this week is a
disquieting image during a time when
food supply is front of mind
till then shell boss is in this country
milk dumping should be banned to
incentivize farmers to find a better way
to market milk it needs to be addressed
because these situations will happen
again in BC this week producers disposed
of three percent of their production
dairy farmer Nick Jensen's doesn't want
a dismantled supply management but he's
also dreading a possible call to dump
some of his milk to dump perfectly good
product that you've produced
that'll be definitely definitely not a
good feeling and I don't look forward to
that day if it does come Erik Sorensen
Global News Toronto still ahead by lack
of support for developing nations in
this pandemic can endanger us all
Kelvin 19 is now spreading to developing
nations which remain underprepared and
underfunded as Reverend Shannon reports
if the world's poorest countries fail to
tackle the pandemic it could cost us all
the diplomatic space between Canada and
the US over facemask exports has been
just one example of how the world has
been reacting to covert 19 3m has not
treated our country well and if they do
great and if they don't they can have a
hell of a price to pay the desire to
close down borders and look after your
own people is natural and understandable
in a pandemic the European Union and
others have also moved to limit some
exports of medical equipment but from
the very start the w-h-o has stressed
the need for the world to work together
this problem can only be solved with
international cooperation and
international solidarity when health
workers are at risk we're all at risk
and the reasoning is simple if covert 19
is not eliminated everywhere then it
will return everywhere one of the
critical issues that we're working on
globally is to have people understand
this is truly a global problem nothing
tells it like this disease which started
around Wuhan but in three and a half
months moved to more than 180 countries
dr. Seth Buerkle is from the charity
GAVI Alliance it has helped vaccinate
hundreds of millions of children against
diseases like cholera measles and Ebola
he says the worldwide lockdown is
already indirectly threatening people at
risk from those diseases as well as
efforts to tackle kovat 19 we also have
21 countries who are beginning to become
short of vaccine supply and the normal
supply has been disrupted because of
airline you know stopping flights to
those countries or closures health care
systems across the developing world
struggle to get medical supplies at the
best of times the World Bank says it
will provide more than 200 billion
dollars of loans to those nations over
the next 15 months
but the money will only be abuse if they
can use it to buy the right equipment
from industrialized nations if they
can't then covered 19 will remain a
threat for everyone
Redman Shannon Doble News London up next
how can a former Bronco heel in this
pandemic
[Music]
we're part of Terry's family and we're
honoring the 40th anniversary of the
Marathon of Hope Terry Fox's family
continues his marathon of Hope which
began 40 years ago the 21 year old died
before he could complete his journey but
he raised more than 24 million dollars
for cancer research the Terry Fox
foundation has raised hundreds of
millions of dollars since it's been two
years since the Humboldt Broncos bus
crash
16 people died and players like Ryan
stretch knit ski suffered serious
injuries he was paralyzed but now Cova
19 is impacting his rehabilitation
here's Heather York's West for Ryan
stress miski getting back on the ice
with teammates means everything a chance
to recover something lost but because of
Cova 19 those opportunities are gone
once again I was on the ice ball four or
five times a week and unfortunately
stopped about just over a month ago
before the pandemic Ryan had been
preparing for a national tournament with
his provincial sledge hockey team and
experiencing gradual improvements after
receiving a spinal stimulation in
Thailand late last year it's been steady
progress you know I was in about four
times a week as well and and it was all
walking for about hours and it was it
was constant work and it's hard but I
mean it's getting way better last week
those physi will appoint and it as well
it's unfortunate and I we certainly
understand why but it's taking a toll on
him mentally more than anything else it
like gave him something to do and
something to look forward to to get out
of the house so now he works out just in
the basement coming from an athletic
background I mean you're you're always
constantly moving four or five times a
week or even six days a week and to have
that all stopped and shut down is it's
tough so kind of got a keep active at
home as much as you can and keep your
mental and physical health up up to par
but the family of six is also counting
their blessings for a year after the bus
crash the family lived in separate rooms
at a local hotel while their home was
renovated to accommodate Ryan's needs
all under one roof again they're trying
to use this time to
Connect we've been doing a lot of
Netflix and laughing and spending a lot
of time together way more than we used
to do I think and I think the kids are
sort of rediscovering each other that's
a family for those moments this family
is grateful after overcoming so much
Heather Yorick's West Global News
Airdrie Alberta and that is global
national for this Sunday I'm Robin Gill
on this Easter we leave you with a
special concert Andrea Bocelli gave a
concert in an empty Cathedral in Milan
it was live streamed to the many around
the world who are locked down during
these extraordinary times but jelly
hopes the sacred songs will inspire all
of us and help heal a wounded earth
pulsing heart thank you for watching
good night